At this point, our only code
module is our main activity.
We'll get back to that
in a little while.
But first,
let's create our intent service.
We're going to call
DetectedActivitiesIntentService.
I'll do this by creating
a new Java class, and
calling it as I said,
DetectedActivitiesIntentService.
So here you can see my new
class has been created for
me, but there's a few things I'm
going to need to set this up.
First of all, there should be
a tag that we're going to use for
logging events and
a constructor for the class.
Here's the tag I'm setting up,
I'm just calling it detection is,
where is stands for intends service and
here's the constructor, and
all I'm just going to do with
the constructor is super the tag.
There's one more thing that I need
to do, and that is because this is
an intent service, I have to get it
to extend the IntentService class.
And we do that right here.
Because I've pasted IntentService in,
and Android Studio recognized
that I haven't imported that yet,
It's asking me if I want to import it,
and yes of course, I do.
You may notice that I have
a red under line here, and
that's because I haven't implemented
on the on handle intent yet.
And if you remember earlier,
we mentioned that you have to implement
that, and you pass the desired intent
to that, so we will do that next.